the bow don't sweat now peace well you
got it's a beautiful day you're gonna
burn my truck
I'm going
hi guys welcome to the fallout shows mod
of the week we're changing the format
just a little bit this week and
showcasing what we believe to be the
best mod the fallout 4 community has to
offer all the way up until the point
where the official mod tools' are
released and we can once more get stuck
into insane and interesting mods this
week we are looking at the b9t combat
suit armor mod by lord of war
the main suit comes in two versions one
being a standard forest camouflage the
other is an institute version with
contrasting white and black armor plates
each armor is available for female and
male wastelanders so no one gets left
out the wings and the arms back and
meant to represent futuristic jetpacks
although not functional yet the mod
author is looking to add the feature in
future updates this sci-fi style dharma
doesn't quite fit in with a grind
covered world of fallout 4 but since in
this world alien exists and the mod no
strikes some resemblance to the Chinese
stealth suits from previous fall outs I
think we could consider this model or
friendly there is an impressive amount
of detail in this armor from the wires
between armor plates to the Oakley faced
helmets winged backpack all these
wonderful details are available for your
viewing in glorious 4k textures with 2k
versions available if your graphics
settings need to be dialed back just a
little I've one enjoyed pairing this
armor with an array of energy weapons to
embrace the science fiction feel of the
piece and since there's a full Institute
variant of the armor I thought that the
Brotherhood of Steel would make suitable
guinea pigs to test out my new suit the
camouflage version fits well outside the
synth loving Institute what I would love
to see a reclaim Brotherhood of Steel
version of this voice of mod as well as
the working jet packs as mentioned
before just so I can blast plasma balls
from the sky like a fallout version of
the Soviet of the Ender's please let me
know what you think of my new dress
sense in the comments section below and
if there is a mod that you would like to
see on the show then feel free to leave
it in the comments or tweet at us using
the hashtag GS fallout the link for the
mod will be in the description below so
make sure you try it out
and let us know what ventures you had in
your tasty new attire until next week
I've been Dave thank you so much for
watching and stay safe out there
wasteland err